the Battle Royale game-mode isn't
exactly new but you can thank player on
owns battlegrounds for its current
mainstream spotlight after Club G sold
tens of millions of copies on Steam
during its early access period alone
there's bound to be a wave of games
trying to capitalize on the genres
exploding popularity as of now though
fortnight Battle Royale is the
front-runner and challenging Club G's
dominance and while many have dubbed for
tonight's rendition a pub G clone
there's a lot that make these two
drastically different the first thing
that I'll jump out to you is the
presentation pub G has a realistic
military inspired look while fortnight
looks like a bright colorful cartoon
oddly enough both games use epics Unreal
Engine 4 despite the divergent graphical
styles these games are also born out of
disparate foundations at its core pub t
shares much of the same DNA as its
predecessors
Brenden player unknown green himself
helped create the original battle royale
mods for ArmA eventually leading to h1z1
king of a kill which was the premiere
battle royale game just before pub G
busts it onto the scene
however pub G offers a more accessible
streamlined experience while retaining
the military sim framework that taps
into your tactical instincts so how did
fortnight of all games become the one to
go toe-to-toe with pub G its initial
vision was a mash-up of gears of wars
horde mode and Minecrafts construction
mechanics driven by a loot grind to hook
players at first glance a game that
controls fast and loose almost like an
arena shooter doesn't seem right for
Battle Royale
however epic was able to adapt for
tonight into its own battle royale mode
early on and capitalize on this trend
Farah Knight also has two things in its
favour it's free-to-play and available
on PlayStation 4 and Xbox one now pub G
recently hit the Xbox one in an early
access phase but it has a long way to go
to match up to how smooth and stable
fortnight runs even on PC you're likely
to run higher frame rates and have a
lower chance of experiencing game
breaking bugs when it comes to the
overall concept pub G's influence on
fortnight is clear in both games there's
a 60-second warm-up hundred players are
crammed into an air vessel and parachute
down an island for a bloody deathmatch
you're continually forced into smaller
zones at random by a lethal circle as a
match progresses you'll never know
exactly where the final firefight will
take place either everyone scrambles for
weapons ammo and health items across the
maps numerous town
and structures you can either do this
alone as a duo or with a squad of four
but it all ends the same
the last person or squad standing is
declared the winner but in practice
these games play very differently most
noticeably Pub Gees rules of engagement
are in sharp contrast with fortnight's
when it comes to pub key player movement
and the act of firing a gun is very
deliberate and calculated tactical
situations rely on positioning and
working the given environment to your
advantage
guns fire with impact and have distinct
recoil patterns and damage models
regardless of your weapon of choice you
have to be precise pub G is all about
precision you can't say the same about
fortnight at least at the same degree of
course aiming is key to winning in
fortnight but the way is salt rifles and
shotguns work is closer to Unreal
Tournament than it is to ARMA rocket and
grenade launchers are also part of
fortnight's Arsenal and traps give
players a chance to exercise a different
type of cleverness because of the nature
of its style fortnight feels much more
chaotic and kinetic and you can't
overlook the importance of building
structures if you want to stay
competitive for a night retains a
crafting from its original mode a
pickaxe that functions as your only
melee weapon is also used to destroy
structures and vegetation which turn
into wood brick or steel with these
elements you build walls stairs or roof
and you can even alter them to have a
window or door it's almost a guarantee
that firing upon an enemy in an open
field will lead to them throwing up a
wall out of instinct to protect
themselves and heighten their chances of
survival scaling mountains and seemingly
hard-to-reach places is made possible
with an ad-lib staircase for tonight's
building mechanics are remarkably easy
to use and crucial to master on the
other hand part of pub keys appeal is
that the clumsy crafting elements of its
predecessors are gone allowing players
to focus on gearing up and executing
tactics to survive each firefight this
helps keep a relatively fast pace and
lower barrier to entry while maintaining
the realistic tactical shooter vibe you
strap on an armored vest and helmet to
protect yourself and weapon attachments
helped get the most out of the deep
roster of firearms inventory management
is a relatively streamlined in pub G but
fortnight simplifies it to such a degree
that you only have to worry about five
inventory slots instead of managing a
weight limit now both games have large
sprawling maps but pub G has vehicles
that are super important for reaching
advantageous positions without getting
swallowed up by the circle of death or
getting gunned down by a praying squad
when it comes to close quarter
encounters playing plug G as if it were
rainbows
six by scouting enemy movement peaking
for sight lines you'll improve your odds
of survival in fortnight destruction is
around every corner if you know an enemy
is on the second floor of a building you
can blow apart the floor beneath them
for a surprise you rack up kills by
getting the jump on opponents in either
game but you can't play pub G like
fortnight and approaching fortnight like
pub G will only get you so far now in
the late game when you get to a
single-digit player count things turn
out drastically different with 49 you
often see enemies creating their own
fort like structures and safe zones
essentially building makeshift houses to
leverage the resources and wit it's not
much of a mystery where the last players
are when you see them exercising their
architectural prowess what often times
pub G's final moments boil down to a
waiting game
who gets spotted first or a risky push
with smoke grenades as your last bit of
cover
it's about seizing a short window of
opportunity when things go from zero to
100 real quick so if you have to choose
one over the other keep in mind that
fortnight is best for those who want to
engage in a form of Base building within
a chaotic shooter that doesn't rely so
much on precision and realism
whereas pub G has the look and feel of a
tactical shooter to drive home the
uneasy tension of Battle Royale the
thirst can be quenched with either game
or both because the thrill of vesting 90
plus other players is rewarding and away
unlike other multiplayer shooters if you
want to keep up with everything that's
happening with player unknowns
battlegrounds or fortnight stick to
gamespot.com
thanks for watching